あ~
小さい時じゃなくて、今
目が…
そう言われるのがすごく嫌でね
お父さん、パパと「くいね」とか見ないって
すごく嫌だったの小さい時
なんかちょっと目似てない?
うん、かもね
わかわれない
これ可愛い
すごい真剣としたもん
なんて思ってない?
待って歩かんとか
うん、ハイティさ
いろんなさ、お守りとか持ち歩いてるんだよ
お財布に
これね、こないたのいいね
うん
本当になんか、今頃になっても
やっと今頃になってた
大輝とも話ができるようになって
すごい嬉しいもん
大輝全然
もう一度に来てくれたり
あ、そうか
いや
えっと
うん
全然面白くないですけど
ちょっときれいなとこだからね
うん
都内なんだけど
だから
もしパパが
うまくに行くのよけたり
なんかしたら
そこに
3人で行けるなと思って
うんうん
うん
え、でも行きたいな
なんかあの
えひひおじいちゃんの
あの
きれいなお庭があるの
だけど
やばいからね
うん
いつも回れちゃうから
あんまり大変じゃなくて
行きゃ回るんだけどね
え、どこ?それって
あのー
六本木から歩けるところ
だから
六本木で待ち合わせればね
一番いいかな
え、行こう
え、もし
パパが来たら
じゃあ行こう
なんかそこ知らないんじゃないかな
どうだろう
普通はね
あのー
会員になってると
お昼とかみんな
あのー
ディスカンプってあるのね
やすくしてくれるんでね
会員じゃないんだけど
あのー
朝またちが
みんなさんいらっしゃったときに
みんなが入ってたからね
あのー
そう
っていうのを
聞かれるのに
「どうするときだけ会員ですか?」って言っても 違うんですよ
「母がいたときはね」とか言うけど でもでも安くなってくれない
そんなちょっと行かないけど 静かなところで
前朝ごはんがとっても美味しかったな 朝がブッフェみたいになってて好きなものを取れたの
だけどコロナになった時にはやめたみたいで
そっか
「そうね、あれとあれ、食い信号で食べるところはちゃんと覚えてくる」
「このオーナーはあんまりごとってんかったです」
「こっちもそうだよ」
「うん、そう」
「あった」
「そういういろんな機械も全然使ってないから」
「全然使ってない」
「あー、これとか、ママ、ほら」
「あー、この写真は持ってる」
「あー、これ」
「これどうやって全部一緒に見るんだろう」
「うん」
「いいかも」
「うん、そう」
「これ、えっと、リキッドママ」
「これママ」
「うん」
「なんか、ママちゃんってやっぱり、ちょうどいいときを選んだろうなと思って、なんか今度あの、やっぱりプレジデントちゃんってあの、アメリカで生まれたらアメリカ人にしてあげるっていうのやめたいらしいのね」
「みんな、みんなそういう人がいっぱい来ちゃうから、かわいい」
「見て、パンチャー」
「あー、そうか」
「うん」
「いいかもいいね」
「いいね」
「これ、2000年」
「2008年」
「あー、みんなそういう人が大きくなっちゃうね」
「ね」
「なんか、めんめんと一緒に言う日本のことかな」
「うん」
「思えてるかな」
「大気」
「そうか」
「えーっと」
「うん」
これ何?
ヒローダ
あ、そう?
うん
ほらこれアミヒローダン
あ、そうか
あ、これメンメン、ほら
え、これメンメン
これヒロー
え、っていうか、何?
かわいい
これどこ?これまだ持ってる?
どうかな?この土地にも分かんない
え、このパンチャム、どこ行ったんだ?
これいつ?
あ、これお正月
あ、そう?
うん
これどこだ?
うん、その頃、もう何年か前のにその頃の方が見るような、髪の毛が真っ白い
今、今少し、少しだけ声でも色を入れてもらってるのよ
あ、うん
うん
だから、昨日、あきこさんに、きれいねとか言われて、そう自然だと思ったって言われて、自然だったのもっと真っ白で
ねえ
昨日の写真がいっぱい
これ、2020…え、2012年だった
ねえ、早いねえ
ほんと
かわいい
うん
これ、あみ
かわいい
うん
あみは小さい時、本当に大きなしかったのね、それでもねえ
なんかあの目がアメリカに着いたんだな
なんか忘れた時
ママが本当に赤ちゃんの待機を抱っこして、空港まで迎えに来てくださったのね。
それでアミちゃんはアブエロがちょうどいらっしゃると待ってるんだって言って、
ママが出た時と同じ格好をして、同じままも座って、カワイトルになっちゃって。
こんな、なんか、アスティックの石があるじゃない。
それに乗せられて、それをまたベッドの上に乗せて。
ママが空港に戻ってくる間、ジュースのままはいたって言ったら、カワイトルになっちゃって。
何それ?
大人しかったんですよってアブエロが喜んでらっしゃって。
そりゃそうよね、そんなとこでアミちゃんは泣いたりしないよね。
え、そう?
これ、コンフィメーションだと思う。
そうかな。
これ、フェンシスキンチャンポルセンターだよ。
まあ、そういう話を聞いたもんね。
うん。
あれ?
タパフィメーションはもちろんいいんだけど、今、何もしてないから、あんまり友達とかいなくて。
前、おにぎり作るのがあったのね。
うん。
あ、ほら見て。
それで、それやってたんだけど。
あ、ほんとだ。
これ、ムーメンに送る。
うん。
これ、なんだろう。
これ、誰のコンフィメーション?
うん。
これ、誰?
これ、誰だろう。
これ、誰のコンフィメーション?
うん。
これ、誰?
誰だろうね。
本当?
どっかに一人だけ、この人は知ってるっていうのがいるのかな?
ファーダーラッスルしか覚えてない。
あ、いたいた。
でも、リキちゃんもみんな一緒に、あの、可愛い。
あ、いいね。
ファーダーラッスル。
これ、ファーダーラッスルかな。
うん。
え、これ、いつ?
今、どこいらっしゃったか知らない。
あの、この間、みんなで、みんなで行ったので、その後、全然、何も、何も言ってないから。
あ、こうすけさんか。
うん。
そうです。
かわいい。
かわいい、これ。
うん。
何か食べて。
この人たち誰?
これ、何か食べて。
これ、これ、これ。
全然覚えてないよ。何これ。
面白い、こういう古い写真が見られるっていうのはいいね。
私もアイバムにみんなだいたい発作りしてて、
ママが生まれた後の、ママは本当に小さい時のアルバムで、ママのとこにあるって言ってたよ、ママ。
この間、駅が見たがってるんだけど、うちにないみたいな、どこ行っただろうって言ったら、うちにあるよって言ってたけど。
あるけど、そんなになかったよ。何冊?
4冊ぐらいアルバムあって、昔からずっとあって、何回も見てるやつ。
ちょっと、元々そんなになかったんだと思う。
あそこ。
うん。
ほんと。
ん
うん本当
だねえ
ん
多分アミか
何これ
これ全部シャッシュテッと電話の写真だと思う
ん
今の何?
これマグロ
これ?
これまだ築地にあのー
マーケットあんついっぱいあった時ね
そうそうそう
今もでも結構いろいろあるんだけどでもあんまり
うん
なんだ
あのー
お店の人とか本職の人たちはいないからね
はっ
だってもっと大きくすればいい。
Good evening.
"Yeah"
"Yes, mom doesn't change Shit in me."
"Bye."
" 익λα Hey, meet up."
"I got a weird knee sign."
"Yes, mommy has a weird Şeyia to be good."
"Yes, mommy has a weird feeling."
"I remember there was a tree in the old place."
"I forgot to go to the old place."
"Oh, yes."
"The old place in the old place is really small."
"I was a little old when I was there."
"Hot? I remember there was a mall that was like a mall."
"There was a Lego house."
"Morl like that?"
"Yes, there were lots of outlets and Lego house."
"And there were a car to rent."
"Oh, that's where it was."
"Print Hotel?" "It's different."
"Who?"
"Oh, yes, Prince Hotel is near the neighborhood."
"Yes, Prince Hotel is near the neighborhood."
見てこれハムした。4匹いたっけ?
いいね。ほんとにこういうふうに入ってるとね。
うん。
あーこれきれい。
うん、ほんと。
うん。
これも全部広くか?
いいです。
かわいい。
はい。
なんかいっぱい入り過ぎて1日かけても全部やれない感じ。
うん。
これは?
これ、えっと。
これも軽井沢の博物館みたいなところである。
うん。
これこれ、これも軽井沢の博物館みたいなところである。
これも軽井沢の博物館みたいなところである。
どんぐい。
誰だ?
かわいい。
かわいい。なにこれ?
大きい方ね。
ああ、うん。マジだったっけ?忘れたな。
これも軽いそうかな。
ああ、これ。
これが、アキコさんの家に行くとき、これ軽いって言ったよね。
ほら、これ、アキコさんの家。
あの、ピッツァの。
さっちょ
これ花
これも軽いじゃん
江戸本どこだろう
これメメの家の近くの公園かも
分かんない
築地の
築地の公園なんてあった
あれ瀬戸岡病院の隣に
いつも行ってる公園あったじゃん
いろんなグランコとかあるとこ
そうそうそう
味わいまで終わるな
あそこでも暑いのよ
なんかこんなに火陰がないんだもん
あそこすごい大きいあのー
んーとー
ジップラインっていうの
あれがあっていつも好きだったの覚えてる
それがいっけー?
あんまりよくわかんない
ほらこれこれ
うん
あうまかと思った
めんめんの一度見やるのさ
あん
車の写真があるかなと思って
あんまりないんじゃない?
あんまりの3年ずっと乗ってなかったし
そう?
そう、一度だけ何故か言った時
パパだけ乗っちゃったりして
得意そうに乗ってたの思い出し
かわいい
これハロウィンのパンプキンかと思う
これ、教会?
うん
嘘
カモスケさんおかしい
え、これ何の時だ?
初世代か何かやった時?
うん、だってアンミとリキと
大輝もやったっけ?
うん
3人
リキさんだけは
それこそファルラーションがね
大子と妹たちと一緒に
嫌だからリキだけ大人と一緒にしようとか
良かったね
よかったね
いや、ファルラーションしか覚えてないね
これもヒーロー
でもあの時まだアンミたち英語できなかったから欲しかったね
そう
かわいい
大輝まだ髪の毛がない
うん
これじゃもっと古いかな
これ、このジャケットまだ持ってるんだよ
うん
あ、そう
どこ?
それ
あ、これ、えっと、靖国神社のお盆のお祭りだと思う
あ、そうか
お正月とかもね、大変なのよね、あそこね
うん
でもこの頃なんかあんまり食べ物売ってはいけなくなってたの、お正月は
え、なんで?
あんまり思うから、みんながもうピックピックみたいになっちゃうからね
あ、そうか、これもお正月じゃん、だってみんなジャケット着てるから
めめいっぱい色々運転してくれてね、毎日
しかも女の子がたくさんのお祭りだと思うよ
同じ車だったし。
すごいよ、22年以上持ったの。
今まで持ってたのは、22年も使った車だったから、すごい良かったけど、もっと小さいの買おうと思うんだけど、ママは絶対反対なのよ。
今はどこ行くんでもパパに送り迎えしていただいて悪いから、やっぱり車がいるよって言ってるんだけど、車にダメなんだよね。
今の電子上といろんなセンサーとか、アポワッチみたいにいろいろ。
難しい?
うん、いや、後ろにさ、なんかあったりするとさ、落としたりさ、そういう風でもっと安全だよね。
うん。
これどこだろう。
かわいい。
クリちゃん、覚えてる?
きる
はっ
いいね、いつも犬がいて
あー
これはどこ?
多分メリーランド
あー、そうか
これでもない、いつだろう
これとか軽い座っぽかったけど
なんか雨来てきたよ
これ知らない
すごい、こうやって本当にね
一体何枚ぐらい
もう何百枚も
持っておけるんだろう
こうやって
これすごい古い
ね、すごいね
あー
ファミリーの写真を撮影しています。
なんでパンチャーっていつも目赤かったんだろう
なんかすごいさ疲れてる感じ
誰だろう
じゃあ中入るそろそろ
これ700円だったんでよくない
メンメン電話見てみて送ったから
今もう見られるはずなんだけど
ちゃんと届いたかどうか確認したいから
どう見られる?